[Musique]
je le dis avec toute ma conviction
l'avortement doit rester l'exception
l'ultime recours pour des situations
sans issue mais comment le tolérer son
qu'il perd son caractère d'exception
sans que la société paraissent
l'encourager je voudrais tout d'abord
vous faire partager une conviction de
femmes
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes aucune femme ne recourt de
gaieté de coeur à l'avortement
il suffit d'écouter les femmes c'est
toujours un drame
[Applaudissements]
c'est toujours un drame
cela restera toujours un drame c'est
pourquoi si le projet qui vous est
présenté tient compte de la situation de
fait existantes
s'il admet la possibilité d'une
interruption de grossesse c'est pour la
contrôler et autant que possible en 10
bat et la femme nous pensons ainsi
répondre au désir conscient ou
inconscient de toutes les femmes qui se
trouvent dans cette situation d'envoi si
bien décrite y analyser par certaines
des personnalités de votre commission
spéciale a entendu au cours de l'automne
1973 actuellement celle qui se trouve
dans cette issue et d'associations de
détresse qui s'en préoccupe la loi les
rejette non seulement dans l'opprobre la
honte et la solitude mais aussi dans
l'anonymat et l'angoissé poursuite
contrainte de cacher leur étant trop
souvent elle ne trouve personne pour les
écouter les éclairer et leur apporter un
appui et une protection
parmi ceux qui combattent aujourd'hui
une éventuelle modification de la loi
répressive
combien sont ils ceux qui se sont
préoccupés d'aider ces femmes dans leur
détresse
combien sont ils ceux qui au delà de ce
qu'ils jugent comme une faute ont su
manifester aux jeunes mères célibataires
la compréhension et la plus morale dont
elle avait un si grand besoin
c'est ainsi que madame simone veil qui
n'avait jamais figuré dans ces sondages
vient en tête devant tous les hommes
devant 55%
madame simone là et dans le grand public
a pu faire largement connaissance lors
du récent débat à l'assemblée nationale
sur l'avortement sera d'ailleurs à
nouveau sur la sellette aujourd'hui
puisque ce projet de loi sur
l'interruption de grossesse revient ce
soir en deuxième lecture devant les
députés
madame veil demeure confiante et elle
nous a dit ce que ce combat car c'en est
un à représenter pour elles
vous avez été en quelque sorte l'avocat
donc de cette fois qu'elle était pour
vous le moment le plus difficile jusqu'à
présent sur le plan sur le plan
personnel certain moment des débats
parlementaires ont été difficiles même
si je me suis rendu compte que certains
propos étaient dues à la passion une
passion parfois justifiées de temps en
temps là ça a été vraiment des moments
difficiles mais je crois que ce qui est
très important je ne sais pas en
définitive comment le texte va se
retrouver tout à fait en fin de parcours
c'est par exemple le vote du sénat que
le sénat est adopté ce texte après les
débats d'une très grande sérénité d'une
très grande dignité et adopter le texte
avec deux tiers des sénateurs je crois
que c'est une chose importante car ça
prouve qu'en définitive il y avait d'un
consensus général est d'ailleurs
ressorti d'un certain nombre enfin un
consensus en tout cas très important qui
est ressorti d'ailleurs 2
certains sondages ont peut être fait si
c'était à refaire seriez vous prête de
nouveau à vous battre sans compter comme
vous l'avez fait pour défendre un texte
sur sûrement là même la même façon
peut-être simplement en tirant parti de
certaines certaines leçons qui vont
donner sur la façon d'appréhender les
problèmes on sur certaines attitudes
mais comme je pense que c'était qu'en
définitive la moins mauvaise des
solutions et que sa porte est comme je
vous ai dit certains progrès je n'ai pas
changé de point de vue et donc je
referais la même chose passante dans ce
débat et même dans ce combat sans
concession
quelle est la conclusion que vous
retirez pour vous personnellement je ne
tire pas de son personnel je crois avoir
pris les choses simplement comme je les
ressentais et de m d'avoir fait les
choses les unes après les autres d'avoir
franchi les étapes et d'avoir fait
chaque petite chose au mieux comme je
pouvais son ton en tirer deux leçons
particulières dont quelles raisons avez
vous accepté ce poste et en particulier
de défendre ce texte est ce que ce ne
sont pas des ambitions j'ai une vie
professionnelle depuis longtemps et
chaque fois que j'ai travaillé quel que
soit ce que j'ai fait que ce soit
l'administration pénitentiaire ou
ensuite à la direction des affaires
civiles quand j'ai travaillé sur des
textes quand j'ai quelque chose à faire
j'aime que ce soit bien fait selon ce
que je pense surtout c'est ce qui me
paraît le plus le plus important c'est
de mettre mes idées
être ministre c'est qu'il occasion
privilégiée de pouvoir réaliser les
choses qu'on pense mais quand on est un
poste même de magistrats comme je lé
texte travailler sur des projets de loi
mon travail c'est est de convaincre les
ministres de mes idées éventuellement je
suis arrivé quelquefois on pas toujours
et en tout pas de faire le mieux que je
pouvais ce qui était alors on travaille
à ressent aussi humilité si vous étiez
un jour vous demander de rentrer dans le
rang même dans un avenir proche
d'accepter auriez-vous pour tout à fait
tout à fait y ait un jour un haut
magistrat que mal ici on vous faisait
balayer les rues vous le feriez bien je
crois que les choses m'intéressent les
gens et les choses m'intéressent alors
je crois que si demain je me retrouve
magistrat ce sera tout à fait tout à
fait égal et j'essayerai de le faire
comme je pense que ça doit être fait
grand événement de la journée je vous le
disais c'est donc l'élection de madame
simone veil -le à la présidence de
l'assemblée européenne et je vous
propose de voir maintenant ce qui s'est
passé il y a à peine deux heures à
l'assemblée de strasbourg
c'était exactement à 21h30 l'annoncé
officielle de l'élection de madame veil
fait par la doyenne de l'assemblée
madame louise weiss était aussitôt
interrompu par un tonnerre
d'applaudissements
madame weill a obtenu la majorité
absolue des suffrages exprimés
je félicite à la veille de son élection
l'adresse les meilleurs voeux pour
l'exercice de son mandat et je l'invite
à prendre place au fauteuil présidentiel
[Applaudissements]
ainsi donc celle que la plupart des
français connaissent pour avoir été
pendant cinq ans leur ministre de la
santé a été élu au deuxième tour avec
trois voix de plus que la majorité
absolue
elle a obtenu 192 voix de la part des
410 député européen noël copains étaient
dans l'assistance tout à l'heure que
madame simone veil et été élu ce soir
avec quelques voix de majorité et que
l'on se demande dans les couloirs ce que
sont devenus les voix des gaullistes ou
les voix des démocrates chrétiens
italien n'a peut-être plus tellement
d'importance ce qui compte je crois ce
qui est important ce qui restera
peut-être même comme une sorte
d'événement historique c'est le fait que
cette assemblée européenne élue pour la
première fois au suffrage universel et
porter une femme à sa présidence est
plus qu'un événement politique c'est je
crois une sorte de signe des temps mais
cette hausse qui quand même un événement
politique qui en tant que telle à sa
signification
simone veil avait été élu en france à la
tête d'une liste qui se réclamait de la
politique européenne du gouvernement et
de la politique du président de la
république elle incarne finalement une
certaine conception de la construction
de l'europe une europe confédérale et
lui faudra donner une existence une
réalité une vitalité à cette assemblée
européenne sans toutefois que les
pouvoirs de cette assemblée soit accrue
il y faudra renforcer l'unité de
l'europe sans pour autant marcher vers
la supranationalité un événement
politique est certes mais un événement
aussi qui je crois dépasse la politique
que l'assemblée européenne est elle une
femme qui a été une des portes et c'est
je crois le signe que l'europe sans
oublier son passé à peut-être commencé à
surmonter son passé lui présente pour
vous cette élection à succès personnel
ou une victoire politique ce soit à mes
côtés je n'ai pas vraiment me suis pas
beaucoup posé la question
je pense que je ne pense pas une
victoire il ya un succès je pense plutôt
à ce que ça représente comme
responsabilité est ce que le fait d'être
une femme est pour vous un handicap ou
un avantage je veux dire que dans ma vie
pendant longtemps le fait d'être une
femme a été plutôt un handicap etc
ensuite j'aurai très mauvaises grâces de
continuer à le dire parce qu'en réalité
je n'aurais pas été ministre si je
n'avais pas été une femme
en ce qui concerne cette présidence je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas c'est
certainement le fait d'être une femme
qui m'a entraîné dans la vie politique
alors si je suis consciente que la
plupart des femmes
la marge très grande majorité sont
encore handicapé du fait qu'elles sont
les femmes
ça n'a pas été vrai pour moi ces
dernières années mais je souhaite que
pour les autres femmes
ce ne soit pas même si elles arrivent
dans les mêmes conditions c'est-à-dire
parce qu'on a besoin d'une femme mais
que ce soit ou normalement les femmes
qui ont exactement les mêmes
possibilités que des âmes simone veil en
alsace vous allez retrouver la tête de
liste aux européennes l'une des têtes de
listes aux européennes mais aussi
l'ancien déporté qui ne peut cacher son
émotion en visitant le corps du scrutin
et de cimetières militaires de ce qui a
été la poche de colmar
reportage véronique sainte olives à
sigolsheim les tombes épouse la colline
et domine un paysage serein au moment où
l'europe se fait simone veil a voulu
associer dans un même hommage juifs
catholiques des musulmans qui lie à 44
ans sont morts sur ce qui est devenu la
colline du sang pendant plomb faire le
rang c'est justement pour que l'europe
soit une terre où il faut vous fait bon
vivre sans discrimination de race de
religion entre tous les hommes et les
femmes de bonne volonté
puis simone veil s'est rendu au struthof
le seul camp de concentration en france
violence du souvenir ce n'est pas être
anti européen de savoir affirmant que
nous sommes fiers de ce passé que nous
nous en souvenons écossais une europe
plus forte qui sera construite si elle
se construit sur notre histoire et ce
qui est important c'est aujourd'hui
d'être ensemble pour la liberté
[Musique]
simone veil témoigne il n'y a pas de
rupture dans l'histoire seulement des
pages qui tournent
la loi veil a aujourd'hui 25 ans cela
fait un quart de siècle que madame veil
avait défendu devant l'assemblée
nationale la légalisation de
l'avortement
la lutte des femmes françaises suap un
combat souvent provocateurs comme nous
le rappelle agnès molinier la guillotine
pour les avorteuse les assises pour leur
cliente de simone de beauvoir à
catherine deneuve
ces scories risques et ces femmes jusqu
aux années 40 en france car elles ont
toutes reconnu publiquement avoir eu
recours à une interruption de grossesse
alors que c'était illégal 343 nom paraît
171 dans le nouvel observateur
on les appelle les [ __ ] les gens
riches pouvaient aller apporter en
suisse les pauvres c'était encore parce
que les aiguilles à tricoter ou les
sondés tout ça et des gens les femmes on
m'aurait été très malade devenait a
prévu stérile où on enlever les ovaires
parce qu'ils avaient des infections qui
se passait donc tout ça si vous voulez a
fait que je veux pas signer pas
progression des signes et passa pas
évident
[Applaudissements]
ces femmes célèbres ne font que relayer
la voix de la rue le combat féministe
est à son comble après la contraception
autorisé en 69
la légalisation de l'avortement devient
le nouvel enjeu en 72 l'acquittement
d'une jeune fille ayant interrompu sa
grossesse et pour les militantes une
première victoire
74 les politiques essentiellement des
hommes prennent pas la mesure de
l'urgence 300 femmes meurent chaque
année d'avortements clandestins contre
certains ténors de son camp simone veil
se bat et elle gagne avec plus de
difficulté que si elle avait été un
homme
je crois que j'ai une femme avait plus
de facilités pour faire comprendre la
détresse des femmes pour faire
comprendre
le problème mais
mais qui n'y aurait pas eu ces attaques
personnelles ce qui se voulait vraiment
humiliante personnellement enfin
s'attaquer à votre personne
aujourd'hui les femmes sont à nouveau
dans la rue elles défendent un meilleur
accès à liv et j'ai un quart de siècle
après le combat de leur mère
[Musique]